merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur général je vous ai écouté avec
beaucoup d'intérêt et lorsque vous
parlez de la police judiciaire on sent
que vous y mettez beaucoup de cœur et
d'expérience et je l'ai tout à fait
relevé votre constat de la situation m'a
paru lucide
et il me semble que vous avez adopté un
par les vrais que tous nos collègues ont
pu entendre dans la description de ce
constat
ça n'est pas parce qu'une réforme
suscite des critiques qu'elle est
mauvaise
mais il est vrai que peut-être les
critiques peuvent servir à l'améliorer
j'ai entendu dans votre propos à
certains nombre de clarifications qui
étaient nécessaires ou de rappel qu'il
ne l'était pas moi notamment sur
l'autorité des parquets
sur le déroulement des enquêtes et comme
vous l'avez souligné c'est une exigence
du code de procédure pénale qui a une
réforme d'organisation ne saurait
remettre en cause encore faut-il que les
organisations soient bien compatibles
avec cette exigence et je pense que vous
y avez réfléchi que les évolutions que
vous pouvez imprimer à cette nouvelle
organisation pourront encore conforter
cela moi j'ai deux types de questions
qui rejoignent d'ailleurs
l'intervention d'autres collègues
la première catégorie de questions
comme des états généraux de la justice
l'ont dit aussi vous évoquez la
simplification de la procédure pénale
et je crois qu'il y a un consensus sur
ce point simplement en évoque toujours
cette question
en considérant que une fois qu'on a dit
il faut refaire un code de procédure
pénale plus simple
on a tout dit est-ce que vous pourriez
nous donner quelques pistes de ce qui
vous paraîtrait indispensable pour
faciliter la tâche des enquêteurs tout
en maintenant les protections
nécessaires pour les personnes qui font
l'objet des enquêtes puis le deuxième
point c'est me semble-t-il
un point que vous n'avez pas
suffisamment à mes yeux abordés
et je rejoins monsieur bonne Carrère et
peut-être aussi
mes collègues socialistes sur ce point
moi j'ai plutôt l'impression qu'il y a
une crise d'évocation
j'ai plutôt l'impression que la police
judiciaire qui était à l'intérieur de la
police nationale tout de même
une activité particulièrement noble et
recherché
est aujourd'hui délaissé
mais si je me trompe faut me le dire
parce que
si je le dis c'est parce que j'entends
les procureurs
j'entends certains et directeurs et
départementaux et certains responsables
des services
régionaux de police judiciaire et je
m'inquiète
parce qu'en effet je continue moi à
penser que cette tâche est parmi les
plus nobles de la police les plus
exigeantes et je me demande s'il n'y a
pas une évolution
qui va de pair avec un certain nombre
d'évolutions de la société qui fait que
les exigences de ce métier et sa
complexité croissante
qui va de pair avec la complexité
croissante de la procédure pénale
décourage l'évocation et ça n'est pas
une réorganisation même bien faite
ce type de problème
c'est une réflexion
sur
la carrière le métier est peut-être même
aussi les avantages du métier
en contrepartie des contraintes
particulières qu'il impose quel est le
niveau des recrutements actuels par
rapport au passé et quand je dis niveau
c'est pas seulement une question
d'effectif c'est aussi une question de
qualification
des personnes qui se dirigent à la
police judiciaire pourquoi y a-t-il si
je ne me trompe pas une préférence pour
d'autres missions au sein de la police
nationale avez-vous fait une analyse
approfondie de ces questions
Connaissez-vous les raisons pour
lesquelles
une telle situation si
vous en partagez le constat existe voilà
mais deux questions donc code de
procédure pénale qu'est-ce que vous
attendez d'une réforme du code de
procédure pénale et l'évocation
comment les conforter merci
[Musique]